Ruth Bader this morning as we celebrate
the start of women's History Month
Amazon books editorial director Sarah
Gilman brought us some of her favorite
books by and about remarkable women good
morning how you doing great how are you
all right so let's start off with a book
that we just mentioned a is for awesome
23 iconic women who changed the world I
already like the cover covered maybe you
recommend someone on the cover that's
Malala yep I love this so this is a
board book it's by influencer Eva Chen
and it's just so much fun it highlights
all these amazing women everyone from
sort of the expected like Ruth Bader
Ginsburg to the unexpected there's Nobel
prize winning crystallographer Dorothy
Hodgkin so you will definitely learn
something when you read it I read this
to my boys all the time and they
absolutely love it I'm taking that one
home I'm thinking I want to get that one
too we'll we'll get it to we'll get to
the World of Sports dominated by men you
said but the author of your next pick is
working to change that yes so this is
good for a girl Lauren fleshman and I
feel like if you don't know her name you
should she is a retired Elite Runner and
her peers include Paula Radcliffe and
chalane Flanagan but I think more people
don't know who Lauren is and they
absolutely should so this is part Memoir
and a part rallying cry for female
athletes who just face this insane body
pressure to have this ideal body that
can have really horrible effects later
in life everything from osteoporosis to
infertility title now the fans of uh the
podcast serial recognize the next author
who was turning the attention to herself
right so Robbie ashadri this is called
fatty fatty boom boom and she was a
lawyer for Adnan Saeed so her family
moved from Pakistan when she was just a
little girl and they quickly discovered
all the fast and greasy food that
America had to offer and it kicked off
this lifelong battle with her weight and
it's humbling to read about a woman who
has done so much she's so accomplished
but really her self-worth is what's on
the scale next book you call it
eye-opening and refreshingly Frank
Danielle Prescott yeah this is token
black girl it's a memoir by a fashion
and Beauty Insider who grew up right
outside of New York in a really affluent
Community where she was one of the only
black people and she felt ashamed by her
Blackness she's reading books like Sweet
Valley High and where Perfection equals
white and blonde and she didn't yeah she
didn't fit into that so she goes into
the worlds of magazines and realizes
like firsthand the disproportionate
effect that these can have on black
women and girls and finally there's a
new Memoir by Pamela Anderson yes this
is love Pamela this is slightly
unexpected for women's History Month I
feel like the 90s were not kind to women
in the public eye and a lot of us myself
included kind of wrote Pamela Anderson
off because of how she looks or what we
read about her but this book is really
her strip bear she is so vulnerable in
it and she tells a story in her own
words it includes her original poetry
and you see her commitment both as a
mother and she's got the documentary too
I hear great things about the book and
the documentary it's good to see Pamela
getting her just do everybody is raving
she finally gets her voice which I think
is what this month is about I like you
even said Sarah many people wrote her
off including me yeah oh she's great
making it clear thanks sorry Pamela no
I'm sorry Pamela it's good to have you
always have good suggestions thank you
so much